You talked a lot about meaning in life and how that's all been lost to us,
uh,
in our,
in our modern world.
Based on your work and maybe in like the attitude you see in your students.
Are you optimistic about regaining that meaning?
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean so well on most days but I need,
so again,
one of the things that's hopeful,
there's meaning in life is such a hot topic now in many aspects of cognitive
science.
It's a hot topic in philosophy,
very hot topic in psychology doing work on it.
My lab,
the consciousness and the wisdom study labs.
We just did a huge m Turk study and we found that there's a significant,
I'd like to know,
not just statistically significant,
but a significant correlation between,
um,
if people have mystical experience and how meaningful they rate their life and
then,
and then trying to find out,
okay,
what is it in the experiences sort of doing most of the heavy lifting and in
this lines up with other work by someone's Samantha Hanselman and others that
it's sort of the insight,
like machinery recognition is sort of this making coherence making sense,
right?
That's the level at which you can improve people's meaning in life.
And it,
it's,
it's being able to again,
trigger these kinds of experiences with reliable systems,
a steak or technologies that are set within an intellectually and culturally
validated,
right.
Um,
worldview and framework that I think is doable for us now because I think,
I think all the pieces,
there's so many good people doing work on all of the pieces and we're,
we're making pretty significant understanding and all the components and there
is great.
And on the other side,
right.
There's great cultural hunger for all of this stuff.
And so I see this confluence picking up speed.
Now I'm not,
I'm not,
I think there's,
I don't believe in destiny or anything like that.
And this can all go wrong in many ways because we're in a,
we're in a very tight race.
Cars trying to get this addressed is,
is meshed up with other horrible things we're facing in our culture.
Like there's political,
socioeconomic,
environmental issues that are pressing on us and a very urgent manner.
Well,
one of the things he talked about is we had,
we used to have universities,
this is where we get knowledge and then we had other places where we'd get
wisdom.
The monastery.
Yeah.
But now there's nowhere that we get wisdom anymore.
That's right.
I love to do that.
In the class I'll say,
well,
where do you go for,
for information or the Internet,
where do you go for knowledge?
You know,
the university science and where do you go for wisdom?
And then there's this and there's this stony silence.
Well then I want to say,
well,
you know,
foolishness is something much more than just ignorance,
right?
You know,
ignorance is just a lack of knowledge where it's foolishness is,
you know,
you're caught up in,
a,
a compelling pattern of self deception and self destruction.
And that requires a lot of intervention.
We know this because this is why we have therapists,
right?
Yeah.
It's unfortunate that we have sort of lost,
I don't know what to call it,
the cultural commitment to making this a central issue that we,
uh,
aid people in their lives.
Like we just,
as a culture,
we're not doing that
and we're paying for it,
right?
We,
yeah.
We have a mental health crisis.
If you have all kinds of,
you know,
deaths of despair on the rise.
We,
we have people,
we have increasing,
um,
sense of nihilism and cynicism and our culture.
It's eroding our political institutions at a very rapid rate.
All this kinds of stuff we're paying for ready.